welcome to this video playing door on a
teammate of mine yeah let's see what can
we do here the French okay let's do
something something crazy yeah it's a
real French specialist yeah I could have
this was to be expected he's looking at
the Rubenstein at the moment it seems ok
so we have a completely non theoretical
position interesting let's see what what
we can do here let's fianchetto yeah
that's not a bad position for white
nothing special but you can easily play
it f5 maybe in them in the mix yeah he
has seen that I wanted to play Wikibon
fruity one is a mysterious rook move
came yeah I didn't want to play this
what let's let's correct it ok so 14
it's going for g6 mm-hmm
yeah I wonder if 95 is a move I have to
do something like that at one point the
the bishop trade is not ideal but ok
let's at least an interesting position
you probably will go 95 at some point I
wonder c4 is a move I'd certainly
debatable ok let's look at this long
diagonal black it's certainly completely
fine here it's got a very solid position
ok just covering c2 okay okay come on
let's let's do let's do something here
maybe it's it's not a very solid choice
but I don't want to sit in Wade all the
time maybe g5 and I chief is possible to
play of course at 4s weekend this could
could hurt me he is playing Queen B 7 ok
that's possible 97 f five if you can be
problematic now very easily ok that's
definitely a point 97 there's also night
takes a form
okay now that's not really great
disposition now g4 was was really a bit
dicey to play that okay he cannot take
okay cannot take only five number of
times what I wanted to say ok so here my
idea was to play this and possibly
trying to sacrifice on h5 it doesn't
really look like it should work but the
night on g3 is also having a look at
this f5 square so in case of 1975 I can
take it
hmm interesting
that I didn't really think about okay
night before I can still play that yeah
that's probably the best check oh this I
didn't see is this working I've Knight
f6 right
I always have 90 f 6 year winning a
piece
check okay it's really just a piece
black resigns yeah those are very
difficult kind of position here with
lots of pros and cons yeah both sides
are not ideally placed I have weakened
myself with this Jeep horn push but I'm
not really sure if it is bad it gains
some space and yeah it has some points
on those those dark squares I mean of
course black shouldn't you shouldn't
lose like that but it's some km/h from I
don't really know if h4 is any good this
part is exposed I thought you should
just keep the position and I don't know
maybe still 97's there's something wrong
with that I mean I did I definitely
cannot sacrifice on h5 this is not
possible I would have played I would
have played King back to to allow things
like that maybe at one point yeah and
maybe maybe I can take you later on each
fiber black is okay yeah definitely ta I
was this is somewhat alone in this pawn
I'm not sure that this is any good he
obviously played with the idea to take
here but this is just just giving away
in peace queen takes also neither sex
winning the Queen
yeah I'm here the position is equal the
g4s yeah certainly debatable but it made
the game a little bit more more sharp
let's say maybe aged three years
interesting keeping the tension yeah
that's not not interesting that's better
actually not better like black is it's
worse or anything but this is keeping
the tension years is more interesting as
now we cannot move they have six night
because then I would always take and he
does never ever want to take himself to
open up the age file hmm this is bet I
am g5 was a bad decision one of those
quick moves without thinking very much
now here it's probably about equal this
position okay thanks for watching